happy new year everyone and merry
christmas it is still christmas
christmas is more than one day it is 12
days long and of course
happy recovery from kovid which if you
are like me and most other people i know
you got over christmas and are now
recovering from yes
the knolls family like so many of you
celebrated christmas and the new year
with a full-blown case of the rhona
which frankly was perfectly fine in my
opinion because it gave all americans
one of the greatest christmas presents
of all
as kovids spread through the country
like wildfire among the vaccinated and
the unvaccinated conservative and
liberal alike the liberal establishment
completely changed its story on the
virus and the vaccines and even the
masks it turns out
that we conservatives we skeptics we
ordinary normal people
were completely right
about everything and they the libs and
the establishmentarians
and all the rest of them were completely
wrong about everything and we are
finally being vindicated in 2022 for
something that we knew all the way back
in 2020 before two years of 15 days to
slow the spread fa la la la la la la la
la i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from our last episode what was
that a week ago two weeks ago from
yazgirl seven says i shared your shows
on my facebook and they have restricted
my account saying that fact checkers
said the info i was sharing is false i'm
so mad the media is so full of lies and
i have to listen to shows like yours to
get the truth well it's very kind thank
you for listening to the show to get the
truth i'm sorry that your facebook
account was restricted because you
shared
my shows which said true things and not
false things but the silver lining here
the good news is that because the
establishment has completely changed its
tune on kovid on on the vax on the virus
on the masks on the mitigation efforts
on just the whole thing
and now they agree with me and what i've
been saying for two years
maybe you'll get your facebook account
back but more likely probably not
because the
ruling class
really has no integrity whatsoever so
you got to do things for yourself you've
got to improve your lot in life
yourself through prayer
right through the grace of god and also
through your own effort and cooperation
and when you want to work on yourself
i'd recommend you check out echelon i
love my echelon i really do i hate
working out i hate going to the gym and
truly never do that but i love my
echelon because echelon brings the gym
home
when you want to reach your fitness
goals a lot of people are thinking about
that these days it really helps to have
world-class instructors like nicole
griffin and michael brown choreographing
classes with music from your favorite
artists you get a community of hundreds
of thousands of people who can give you
that extra push echelon gives you that
echelon is the affordable way to get the
workout equipment the workout community
and an instructor's motivation right in
the comfort of your own home with
echelon you can work at any time day or
night
crush your fitness goals we put the baby
to bed i'll go up and do an echelon
class you can do it 10 minutes 20
minutes to hour hour and a half it's
really whatever
you are
most focused on most comfortable with
you can obviously change it over time
it's great right now for a limited time
podcast listeners get up to eight
hundred dollars off msrp to get this
exclusive podcast discount text knowles
canon wles to 81 81 81 text knowledge
can wles to 81 81 81 to get 800 bucks
off msrp that is knowles text it to
818181 message and data rates may apply
see terms for details i had covid
i had it i know a lot not all of you had
kovid but i had it
i had i had the real covid
we had a test
the test was positive
it was the real deal
i now am fully convinced as a result of
getting covet again and this test that
what i had two years ago before we had
tests was also covid because it was the
same thing except this time it was a
little more mild
the symptoms of covet as reported in
yahoo news this is from a study from
norway
they said the symptoms of covid the most
common symptoms
are cough
runny or stuffy nose
fatigue and lethargy sore throat
headache
and fever and then to a lesser degree
reduced taste and reduced smell
meaning that the symptoms of covid are
the symptoms of the common cold or the
flu as we've been saying from
the beginning i don't totally want to
unders under sell it it it was worse
than a lot of colds i've had
and some people had it worse than other
i had it worse than some of my other
friends i've said on this show now for
months i don't think it's a good idea
to publicize one's vaccine status
because we are living in a biomedical
security state where you can lose your
entire life and livelihood if you
if you
uh don't go along with whatever the
whims of the ruling class are on the
vaccines so i
i don't think it's a good idea for you
or anyone else to publicize that you
haven't had the vaccine or you have had
the vaccine or you've got 17 boosters or
whatever all i will tell you is
my whole family had covid over the break
a number of my friends all around the
country had covid over the break
some of those people
were not vaccinated some of those people
were vaccinated
some of those people are super duper
covered crazy and had the boosters and
or as gung-ho on the fouchy advice as
they could possibly be
and i'm just speaking anecdotally
there was no rhyme or reason to who got
kovid there was no rhyme or reason to
who got it more severely or less
severely some people who were not
vaccinated got kovid the mildest of all
some people who were vaccinated and
boosted got covid really really bad
we were also told that children and
babies don't deal with covet
as terribly as adults do i tell you just
anecdotally
little baby knowles my son apple of my
eye 11 months old he had it worse than
any of us did
and so
i'm not merely saying that we were right
about everything and that the fear
mongers were wrong about everything i'm
i'm also pointing out that the elite
ruling class who have told us they know
the science and they're following all
the science and we have to trust them
they have no idea what they're talking
about and the things that they told us
about the virus the things they told us
about the vaccines the things they told
us about the masks and the mitigation
efforts they were just wrong they were
just bunk and now they are admitting it
the only reason that i'm probably i hope
this episode of the show doesn't get
taken off of the internet is because
i am now agreeing with the ruling class
and the media and the public health
experts and the politicians who just so
happen to have adopted the things that
i've been saying for two years where i
have at various times been censored like
like that lady in the comments uh
earlier said that sometimes the shows
will be taken off of youtube i i want to
point out the
what i'm describing is just an anecdote
right my experience of cove in my family
my friends
but the plural of anecdote is data
okay you get enough anecdotes and then
you've got data
and what we are seeing even the ruling
class say now is that the reality of
this virus is very different than they
told us it would be the libs used to
tell us
when they first sold us on the vaccines
they told us that the vaccines were
going to stop you from contracting the
virus or transmitting the virus
there's been over a 20 to one return if
you had put that money into an s p 500
and reinvested the dividends you come up
with something like 17 billion dollars
but you think it's 200 billion dollars
here yeah you're okay you're not gonna
you're not going to get covet if you
have these vaccinations these vaccines
are highly highly effective vaccinated
people do not carry the virus don't get
sick they're really really good against
variants everyone who takes the vaccine
is not just protecting themselves but
reducing their transmission
to other people and allowing society to
get back to normal get your first shot
and when you're due for your second get
your second shot a key goal is to stop
the transmission to get the immunity
levels up so that you get almost no
almost no
uh infection going on whatsoever when
people are vaccinated they can feel safe
that they are not going to get infected
so you heard you heard it from the
horse's mouth or maybe some other part
of the horse what they said is
if you get the vaccines you won't
contract the virus you won't get it
if you get the vaccines you won't
transmit the virus the vaccines are
really really good against variants all
those same people who are peddling those
lies admit that it's not true
what they can't do anymore is prevent
transmission you know we didn't have
vaccines that block transmission we got
vaccines that help you with your health
but they only slightly reduce the
transmissions we need a new
new way of doing the vaccine the level
of virus in the nasal pharynx
of a person who's vaccinated and
infected
is the same level as the level of virus
in the nasal parents of an unvaccinated
person reports from our international
colleagues including israel suggest
increased risk of severe disease amongst
those vaccinated early
and if you look at israel
which has always been a month to a month
and a half
ahead of us they are seeing
a waning of immunity not only against
infection
but against hospitalizations
and to some extent death the booster
might actually be an essential part
of the primary regimen that people
should have there you get the idea it
goes on and on
none of the things they originally told
us turned out to be true about the
vaccines now do not let them get away
with this don't accuse me of
misinformation facebook or youtube or
whatever you heard it from the very
people the very public health experts
who then changed their story and
relieved themselves on our legs and
decided to tell us that it's raining
which is why the people pushing this
stuff have no credibility because they
were wrong that's not our fault that's
not the fault of the skeptics and that's
not the fault of the people who are
spreading information around youtube
it's their fault they got it wrong so
they don't have credibility and people
are absolutely 100
justified in not believing what these
craven
lying deceptive dishonest incompetents
tell us
a u.s navy warship
is being held right now off of the coast
of south america it's not
or rather it's being held off the coast
of america and not deploying to south
america
because of an outbreak of covet
there's an outbreak of covet on the uss
milwaukee
it uh is not
not deploying because there's an
outbreak among a 100 percent vaccinated
crew
crew totally 100
you have to get vaccinated over your
medical objections over your religious
objections especially if you're in the
military tough you're not getting an
exemption you have to get vaccinated
that's because we need a fighting force
that's ready to deploy except we can't
because even with a 100 vaccinated crew
there's still an outbreak of covid
if there are
debilitating outbreaks
that prevent
ships from fulfilling their mission
even with 100 vaccination then the
vaccines are not doing their job period
and the ruling class knows it and so
they're giving up the narrative now joe
biden comes out
and he's changing his tune do you
remember do you remember when he was
running for president
it's hard to say he even ran for
president because he mostly hid in his
basement for the whole time and just
waited for corrupt election officials in
in his crony states to change the rules
to make it easier for him to win but but
he in some way he did a few campaign
events at least and he went out there
what did he say he said i've got a
federal plan
and i as president i'm gonna shut down
the virus
i'll put in place a plan to deal with
this pandemic responsibly i've already
done it i've said it before
i'm not gonna shut down the economy i'm
not going to shut down the country but
i'm going to shut down the vote before
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm not going to shut down the country
i'm going to shut down the virus
i'm going to shut down the virus not the
country i'm not going to shut down the
country i'm going to shut down the virus
all right that's enough
you could go on for probably 15 minutes
because
joe biden he he knows not very many
things but he sticks to what he knows
all right he's that was the we've got a
federal plan
trump didn't shut down the virus we're
going to shut down the virus when i'm
president that was then this is now and
now he's not going to shut down the
virus
look there is no
federal solution this gets solved at the
state level okay
there's no federal solution
he's not going to shut down the virus if
you want the virus to be shut down it's
going to happen at the state level there
is nothing
the federal government can do according
to joe biden
all right better late than never
[Laughter]
except that it's so cynical it's so
opportunistic this was always true
there's no federal solution
to shut down the virus that was always
true why are they admitting it now
they're admitting it now i actually have
an answer to this
some people seem really flummoxed even
on the right they say why why what's
going on i don't get it i get it here's
why
because
the ruling class
has already gotten what it wanted out of
covid
it already got what it wanted out of
making everyone wear the masks and
forcing everyone to comply with the
vaccine mandates and shutting down the
society and taking power
they already got that
the public health establishment already
got the power we've already reordered
the relationship between the citizen and
the state
the the vaccine mandates are going into
effect
the regulatory state and the citizen and
private employers now there's
there's a new balance of power there
it's much more on the side of the
government there's already been a
massive transfer of wealth the largest
transfer of wealth in human history from
the lower classes to the upper class
shutting down of small businesses lots
more power and money to big businesses
that already happened
the power grab at the governmental and
corporate level has already taken place
over these very long two weeks to slow
the spread the two weeks that turned in
to two years so they got it so you don't
really need to keep it up anymore
it that's done now
the covid lockdown state is having
diminishing political returns
for the ruling class
this was always the one issue that biden
was ahead on
he was losing on the economy he was
losing on foreign policy he was losing
on oil he was losing on manufacturing he
was losing on everything except for
kovit that was the one area where his
approval rating was a little bit higher
but now that's tanked too
and so this is a big loser for them
there's really nowhere else to go
they've already taken the power
so they move on and their puppets in the
corporate media
are dutifully
doing their part to downplay the virus
chris hayes
on msnbc
now says that kovid
why by golly it's just like the flu
there are still people many people
millions who are immunocompromised or
who are otherwise vulnerable due to age
or medical conditions
but for the people who don't fall into
that category and we're talking about
you know 150 million people maybe or
more
those people who are vaccinated
particularly those who are boosted
you know the risk the personal risk of
of being exposed to this went from
something that we hadn't really dealt
with specifically like this before in
our lifetime so we hadn't quite had an
illness this infectious and this
possible to cause serious illness
to something that does look more like
the flu
and the flu of course can still be
dangerous kills tens of thousands of
americans every year but we don't orient
our lives around the flu
so that's closer to the level of risk
that you know 200 million americans or
less than that are now dealing with and
then when you add in the sheer
exhaustion many people feel and i don't
have to tell you this i'm sure because
you're just feeling this yourself many
of you
with the lengths of this disruption
their lives obviously the politics of
the pandemic are just completely
different than they were earlier in the
pandemic
okay there's the key
there is the key what the first thing he
said is interesting too but that second
part is the real key he says and look
obviously
beyond the scientific stuff there it
politically you just can't keep this up
forever
okay so you're admitting you're
admitting that the way policy is being
made on kovid is primarily not
scientific
but primarily political
and you're really seeing that now from
dr fauci which we'll get to in one
second but what about that first part
the first part he says is look the thing
is we're just gonna have to live with
covet and covet you know now it's just
kind of like it's a lot like the flu
do you remember i
i'm old enough to remember i know it was
a long time ago but i'm old enough to
remember
when
some of us
said that two years ago
said in some ways in a lot of ways this
virus is like the flu we called it the
woofloo the wuhan flew
maybe it's a little deadlier maybe
although you know you got to look into
these statistics but sure let's say it's
deadly i'd say it's significantly
deadlier let's say
that it's going to have a really tough
run for a couple of years before
the virulence of the virus diminishes
and it becomes less of a pandemic a
global you know raging pandemic and more
of just an endemic thing that we deal
with every single year
it's we're just going to live with it
we're not going to overcome it by
shutting down society or wearing those
dumb masks or anything it's not that's
not going to stop it we're not going to
shut down the virus
by shutting down society remember when
we we said all that we say it's kind of
like the flu
and we were
accused of being
spreaders of misinformation of being
murderers of killing people
we were accused of being rubes and
idiots and willfully ignorant
and now the liberal establishment is
saying everything that we said
then and they're they're trying to to
cover their derrieres a little bit so
they're saying we'll know but it's true
now we're it's uh that's true now but it
wasn't true that was it was true it was
true them too
because all the stuff you did to try to
stop
the virus and the stop transmission and
to stop infection and it didn't it
didn't work it didn't really work did it
and even joe biden's admitting that even
joe biden is admitting there's just
there's just no
national
solution to this
so yes we were right from the very
beginning
and now the response is primarily
political
they're saying we can't really keep this
up anymore we're having diminishing
political returns so we're just going to
move on and now you've got to get back
to work
okay that's what we're really being told
you've got to get back
to work
the cdc
formerly told us that when you get covet
you need to quarantine for how long
about 10 days maybe longer but at least
10 days you've got a quarantine
now they are saying
that if if you get coveted you need to
quarantine
for
five days
now
i i googled i looked up on google
scholar on j i tried to find the
scientific
reasoning for why they reduced the time
from 10 days to five days you you won't
find the scientific reasoning the
scientific reasoning is not there
there's nothing about the science that
has changed from when they told us it
should be a 10-day quarantine to a
five-day quarantine what changed is the
politics a lot of people are getting
coveted many of you had it over
christmas and so
you all got to get back to work we got
to keep we got to keep making money for
that ruling class get back out there
folks
we actually do have some more work
coming on here at the daily wire we have
a new series
it's called face the mob
face them up you know we back in the
pre-covet days in the in the days before
everything went to pot uh i would go to
a ton of schools every year
and just engage with people the sort of
angry crowds and they would yell at me
and then i would we would have an
exchange and we'd post these clips
online
so since that's much more difficult to
do now and since a lot of constructive
debate doesn't usually happen in 280
characters on twitter we decided
to face the mob digitally so that's out
there now first episode of that is up on
youtube you can go check it out on my
youtube channel it's a lot of fun to
talk to people some of whom agreed with
me many of whom disagreed with me so go
check that out also
do not comply has taken on an entirely
new meeting for the daily wire this week
this friday the supreme court will
convene to hear arguments on the
legality and constitutionality of the
vax mandate that means that this week is
going to be pivotal in our fight against
the biden administration's vaccine
mandate we've got over a million
signatures on our do not comply petition
currently it's vital that the number
increases before friday when you sign
the petition dailywire.com do not comply
you help us send the message that the
american people will not comply so go to
dailywire.com do not comply right now
we're counting on your help to help us
put a stop to this disgusting
horrible un-american tyrannical federal
overreach we'll be right back with a lot
more
the cdc has changed its mind again just
in time for you to get off the couch and
get back to work and start making us
some money darn it uh rachelle walensky
the head of the cdc goes on cnn
says cut that quarantine time in half
and start bringing in those dollars for
big daddy
i want to start with the change in the
cdc guidance that cuts the isolation
period in half if you're asymptomatic so
how did the cdc settle on five days for
everyone
good morning caitlin thanks for having
me so we looked at several areas of
science here first the science science
of how much transmission happens in the
period of time after you're infected we
know that the most amount of
transmission occurs in those one to two
days before you develop symptoms those
two to three days after you develop
symptoms and if you map that out those
five days account for somewhere between
85 to 90 of all transmission that occurs
and then finally the behavioral science
what will people actually do when people
need to get back to work what is it that
they will actually do and if we can get
them to isolate we do want to make sure
that they're isolating in those first
five days when they're maximally
infectious so from what you're saying it
sounds like this decision had just as
much to do with business as it did with
the science
well so i it really had a lot to do with
what um we thought people would be able
to tolerate
even cnn is on to the game even you see
because they always lead with the
science and they say well actually you
know what we've learned is that you're
more likely to spread a virus in the
early days of getting it than in the
later days
yeah duh that of course that's true of
every virus that's always been true yeah
and so we just decided we were going to
cut the time in half and then even cnn
you know can't keep a straight face and
they say
so this is just
politics right this is just because you
want to make more money that you're
telling people to well uh and then she
admits it rochelle wallace admits it she
says yeah yeah this is about what people
will tolerate and what they're going to
do so
in other words
this is primarily about politics this
always has been primarily about politics
and they're finally admitting it
even dr fauci's admitting it dr fauci
goes on tv his favorite place to be most
dangerous place in the world is not in a
coveted hot spot it's the space between
dr fauji and a television camera dr
fauci goes on and he says
yeah just get back to work
the purpose of it was is that given the
wave the extraordinary unprecedented
wave
of infections that we are experiencing
now and will certainly experience
more of
in the next few weeks that there is the
danger that there will be so many people
who are being isolated who are
asymptomatic
for the full 10 days that you could have
a major negative impact
on our ability to keep society running
so the decision was made although it's
not completely risk-free
of saying let's get that cut in half
so that we could have
50 percent namely half of the 10 days
and 50 of that time
people can actually be out with a mask
in society
this weasel listen to his language
the decision was made oh the oh the
decision was made
by whom was the decision made doctor the
decision it was it was said
it was said by whom you jerk it's you
you did it you you guys did it you cut
it in half but why because the science
changed no we decided mr bezos needed a
little more money we we did not want you
disgusting peasant workers to slack on
your job and and we realized that if you
all stayed home when you were sick that
we wouldn't be able to make as much
money for
the plutocratic ruling elite so uh it
was decided by the science
that you would have to go back to work
okay all right you get the picture
you get the picture they're barely
hiding it at all now speaking of work
aoc
took a little vacation and she's in hot
trouble because of it aoc
went down she left the tyrannical state
of new york her own state and she went
down to the free state of florida
good old desantis land where you can do
what you want and breed the fresh air
and have a nice time
so she goes down to florida
while her constituents are dealing with
spike and covid
spiking crime because of
the bad policies that aoc in part is is
supporting
and a spike in all sorts of misery in
new york i did go to new york briefly
over christmas not looking great city
has seen better days let's put it that
way
so she goes she abandons them she goes
to florida on vacation i don't really
begrudge her vacation but it's a bad
look if you're going to make fun of ted
cruz for going to mexico and you're
going to castigate him and yell at him
over that then what's good for the goose
is good for the gander aoc and aoc was
leading that charge screaming at ted
cruz because he went to a sunny place
as there was
as there were problems in his own state
and well aoc did exactly the same thing
and so she got caught and she's a big
old hypocrite as we all know
and her response
was so typical
she said the only reason people were
criticizing her
is because
they want to date her
that republican men
really want to date her and she won't
she won't date them
and so
they're criticizing her
i i saw someone on twitter over the
weekend asked if uh if you had a choice
would you rather date aoc
or be banished to saint helena that's
the island that they banished napoleon
to and that i suggest we banish dr fauci
to
which would you would you rather be
banished to a far-flung island
or date aoc
and it was observed by some people that
uh
you're only going to get peace and quiet
in one of those
situations
so choose carefully
uh here's aoc's exact words quote if
republicans are mad they can't date me
they can just say that instead of
projecting their sexual frustrations
onto my boyfriend's feet you creepy
weirdos starting to get old ignoring the
very obvious strange and deranged sexual
frustrations that underpin the
republican fixation on me women and lgbt
plus people in general
hold on the sexual frustrations
so
if you're critical of aoc it's because
you want to date her and if you're
critical of say the lgbt movement it's
because you want to date
the dudes
so you're you you must be very sexually
confused if you it's you're real you
want to date the transsexuals and the
homosexuals and aoc you're you want to
date all these people you can't make up
your mind
and none of your criticisms are
legitimate
she says these people clearly need
therapy they won't do it they use
politics as their outlet instead it's
really weird
this is the same sort of thing that aoc
said about the fake insurrection on
january 6 you know the worst the
greatest threat ever ever against
america ever in history
she said that she was almost raped
on january 6th
she was almost raped by the
insurrectionists
and then we found out actually she
wasn't even in the capital she was in
her office building which was a
considerable distance from the capital
and the insurrectionists quote unquote
didn't get anywhere near her office
actually was just a cop who was showing
up there just to make sure she was safe
just to protect her
and
the
thought that she was about to be raped
was entirely in her own delusion it was
entirely in her own head this woman
i want to be really polite about this i
don't want to i don't want to be rude
this woman has an extremely inflated
sense of her own attractiveness
she
she's not
i i don't know i'm just speaking for
myself i don't want to date aoc i do not
now nor have i ever wanted to date aoc i
don't know any republican who wants to
date aoc i don't want to be rude and say
mean things about a woman's
appearance or
personality or
but
lady
you
she needs a reality check and i suppose
that's true in many areas
philosophically ideologically
politically
the reason that her comment is
interesting is not because of just how
juvenile it is and how divorced from
reality it is but because it actually is
part of the kind of broader
left-wing reaction to conservative
criticism which is to reject
the legitimacy of any criticism of their
political agenda and to pathologize all
of it
the left
always dismiss dismisses conservative
criticism of their agenda as the result
of some
usually sexual mental illness
some kind of pathology lionel trilling
said this back in the 20th century
he said that there is no conservative
intellectual movement in america
it's just a series of irritable mental
gestures
the reason conservatives
uh perhaps object to redefining marriage
or our sexual ethic is not because they
recognize that the human body has a
nature that our sp our soul and our body
have something to do with one another
that the body has a purpose and that
there is a fundamental political
building block of society such as the
family we could go on and on and on it's
not because of any reasonable arguments
it's because they're fobes
you know they're haters
they're ists
the sexists and the racists and the
phobes and that's why it's all
irrational
and so what they need is not a vigorous
debate
to determine how we want to proceed as a
society what they need is not
deliberation and persuasion what they
need is therapy
what they need is to go be put on some
drugs
or what they need is to go
just be brainwashed they need or they
need to be
ostracized from society
speaking of sex stuff
france
france
is on the verge
of blocking
the major porn sites
france
not the most
sexually responsible
people that has ever existed
france one of the most lecherous
licentious societies
in the history of the world
is about to ban porn why
because the major porn sites
are not willing to ensure that their
users are over the age of 18
and so
a france's
higher audio visual counsel
gave a bunch of porn sites a deadline
for for these new restrictions after
which they would they said they would
seek a court order to block access to
the sites
this is a debate that's gone on in the
united states and throughout the west
for a number of years now should we do
something about porn porn is everywhere
high speed internet ubiquitous porn on
every phone on every computer on any
kids as young as three can access it
and this is probably not good and it's
leading to a lot of problems it's
leading to a lot of physical and sexual
problems for people especially young men
it's leading to a lot of relationship
problems it's leading to a lot of social
pathologies
horrible skewed perceptions of women and
the way that men and women relate to one
another and it's just bad it's just not
good
right so can we do something about it
and you have the libs
and often libertarians
who
want to pretend that hardcore porn
is as american as apple pie and a
natural right protected by the
constitution and enshrined in the
declaration of independence we hold
these truths to be self-evident all men
are created equal they're endowed by
their creator with certain unalienable
rights among which are life liberty the
pursuit of happiness and the right to
watch like three chicks and a goat do
whatever they're going to do on the
internet is that that's in the
declaration i don't think so buster i
don't think you have any right to porn
at all
and contrary to the protestations of the
libs and many libertarians
you can't you can just ban porn you can
do it you can ban it or you can at the
very least heavily restrict it you can
but we can't ban yes you can you can
it's fine we can
we have heavily restricted porn for most
of american history
and even france is doing it
for goodness sakes if france has the
moral high ground on sexual matters
something has gone wrong in your society
and it's time that we reclaim that
we can do it we have
not just individual rights and
increasingly few individual rights
but we also have higher
political rights
that's the right of a community to set
standards
and for the past 30 40 years
what the left has duped the right into
believing is that the only thing that
matters is the individual right and then
they make up a bunch of individual
rights the individual right to sleep
with whoever you want the individual
right to redefine marriage individual
right to mutilate your body so you look
more like a woman if you're a man or
vice versa the individual right to look
at porn the individual right to do drugs
the individual right to do all you don't
those aren't real rights first of all
and
one of the reasons those aren't real
rights is because they contradict
the
the true good and the common good but
they also contradict the political
rights of a community to set standards
communities have the right to
pass blue laws and say that you can't
buy
alcohol on sundays for instance that's
always been recognized as a right in
america
we have the right to restrict certain
obscenity in the public square
we have the right to restrict certain
pathological behaviors
and we have the right just as france
realizes to restrict porn so do it
we got to do it speaking of different
views of sex
around the world
this coming march
iran will officially join the u.n
commission on the status
of women
a lot of people think this is
very silly because women
have some restrictions on their rights
and liberties in iran to say the least
so people are really attacking this i
think
really
before we
accuse them maybe we ought to take a
look at ourselves
it is very silly
that iran finds itself
on the
uh
the council on the status of women for
the united nations that is very silly
but instead of dunking on iran
maybe we ought to just take a little
look in the mirror okay because
women in america
are
increasingly
miserable
this is not a
wonderful paradise for women
women
don't actually have it all that great in
america these days and it's getting
worse and worse since second wave
feminism over the past 50 or so years
as
can be measured by social scientists
women's happiness has declined
both in absolute terms and relative to
the happiness of men
they're getting more and more and more
miserable
today because of the transgender
movement women are losing their ability
to
use their own bathrooms
women are
losing the ability to compete on their
own sports teams women are all the
awards now are going to men who are
pretending to be women
what is the great freedom of women in
america
what a lot of
liberals would tell you
is that women have it so great in
america because they have the right
to
to do porn they have the right to go on
onlyfans.com and sell their bodies like
they are just flesh
and make some money prostituting
themselves that's one of the women in
iran don't have that right but in so
that's why it's wrong for iran to be on
the u.n women's council but it's good
for america too women in america they
don't have to deal with the patriarchy
of one man loving them for their entire
lives and having a stable marriage and a
stable
building block of society no no women in
america haven't much better they
get to be used by men for decades until
they're no longer as physically
attractive and then they get to be
discarded and they get to spend the rest
of their lives alone working in the
widget factory
isn't that isn't that so great
wow wow we need to give lectures to
everybody
maybe not maybe actually
i can't believe i'm saying this but
maybe some of the feminists
who are critical of
things like our hookup culture some of
the feminists who are critical of some
of the excesses of second wave feminism
maybe some of the conservatives
who have been critical of this whole
project maybe they have a point
and maybe
maybe we're actually not doing such a
great job of taking care of women we're
the libs and a number of republicans are
trying to draft women into combat right
now
this is a major political fight that
josh hawley probably stopped but who
knows it's going to come back up again
we're so great to women in america that
we are going to send them to be
killed by jihadis in the middle east
that's how great we are uh i don't think
so maybe there's a good opportunity
for introspection i don't know
you're seeing this right now on jeopardy
uh dude just became
the woman with the highest overall
winnings
in jeopardy history
women in america are actually put upon
enough now that they can't even win the
women's awards jeopardy contestant
thomas schneider who now goes by a
woman's name and dresses like a woman
and says that he's a woman he has just
earned more money than any female
competitor in jeopardy history and
larissa kelly who previously held the
distinction as the woman with the
highest all-time winnings
just congratulated
thomas schneider and said well it was
fun to hold a jeopardy record for a few
years but it's been even more fun to
watch
jeopardy set new standards for
excellence on the show and off
congratulations to amy that's the name
that this man is going by on becoming
the woman with the highest overall
earnings in the show's history this is
this is probably the most painful part
for women of this new transgenderist
regime
is they have to pretend that this is
great
do you remember when the dude the giant
dude on the u penn women's swimming team
beat all the women's records and then
the women would privately say to
journalists off the record anonymously
they would say you're not off the record
but but on background i suppose and
anonymously they would say
this is terrible we hate this but we've
all got to applaud because we'll be
called haters
so this woman has to say oh it's great
that the men are taking all the women's
stuff
i i'm really happy about that they're
setting new standards of excellence the
new standard of excellence according to
feminism and transgenderism
is
men
that's the that's the new standard of
excellence
and conservatives
i think are not really serious about
stopping this
right conservatives conservatives still
do things like
they'll they'll call men who pretend to
be women they will call them by his he's
a biological male
this person
amy they'll use the women's name they'll
say amy schneider on jeopardy he
this person they often don't even use
the pronouns is a biological male
as though there were any other kind of
male
it's the he's a biological male but he's
a spiritual female the biological male
video is a psychologist no he's just
it's just a dude and when you when you
add the modifier biological to male you
are granting the premise that there are
different types of male and female and
that some male or kind of they can also
be female or no
i don't think conservatives
have the hutzpah to stop this
because in order to stop this stuff
it's not enough to repudiate only the
weird sex aspect or the fact that
obviously men are not women and women
are not men and they can't become one
another
you also have to repudiate
individualism
you also have to repudiate the excesses
of 20th century libertarianism
you also have to repudiate the idea that
well anthony kennedy said this in the
planned parenthood casey decision that
man has the right to create his own
concept of existence you also have to
repudiate the idea that we can do
whatever we want to do so long as it
doesn't hurt other people which is a
dubious concept to begin with because
when you have a society doing all sorts
of terrible things that is going to
affect other people because we live in a
society together because man is the
political and social animal and
politics in general is just what we all
do together so yeah you're gonna have to
repudiate that are you willing to are
you willing to say no you can't mutilate
yourself and get the surgery no you
can't pretend to be a woman even in the
confines of your own home you can't
because that is neces if you're a woman
in your own home you're a woman in
public and we're all gonna have to
acknowledge that
live and let live you do you you you do
you all do me it doesn't work in a
society
it just leads to social breakdown and it
leads to social breakdown just as surely
when the conservatives do it as when the
libs do it and we're in this moment now
where we're seeing massive upheavals of
our way of viewing ourselves and our
relationship to our government and the
way society functions and we're saying
that the covid
the kovid tyranny has been really at the
forefront of that this is a great time
to ask ourselves this question are we
going to just keep going along in the
same process of failure that we've been
keeping up for years and years and years
or is it a new year is it a new year and
a new us and a new opportunity to chart
a course for what we want our country to
look like i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knoll show merry christmas happy
new year see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show